vous connaissez sans doute la règle de
pièces touchées pièces à jouer aux
échecs ou encore pièces lâché coup
validée et bien Gary Kasparov le
champion du monde à bafoué cette règle
et tricher en quelque sorte en 1994 au
célèbre tournoi de Linares et la front
avec les Noirs Judith polga
âgé de seulement 17 ans à l'époque et
dans cette position il joue cavalier ses
5 et se rend compte au dernier moment
qu'il y a une tactique qui permet de
gagner la tour du coup comme si de rien
n'était il repose son cavalier en 17 et
au bout de quelques secondes décide de
jouer cavalier F8 cette fois il profite
du fait que son autre tour garde la case
donc il y a pas de tactique Polgar
interloqué n'a pas osé se plaindre elle
ne savait pas en réalité que la
télévision espagnole filmer la scène et
que la preuve donc castor fallait bien
lâcher sa pièce existait interroger plus
tard par les journalistes blog de Bakou
a dit ne pas avoir eu conscience de la
chaise sa pièce et donc avoir la
conscience tranquille mouais à d'autres